we have to come terms with a reality
maybe it's a new reality I don't know
Donald Trump and Carrie Lake aren't like
Hitler okay that's not what I'm saying
but the growing fad of right-wing
rallies by people especially when they
aren't running for elected office to
fire people up with their authoritarian
rhetoric and right-wing populist
rhetoric are in the style of the rallies
that used to be done by Mussolini and
Hitler and others not saying Trump is
Hitler not saying Kerry lake is
Mussolini okay but understanding the
history if you have an understanding of
the history you could come only to this
conclusion the latest example is that
Kerry Lake who lost her race to be
Arizona's Governor she's holding a rally
called a save Arizona rally presumably
to save Arizona from what I don't know
maybe Katie Hobbs the person that
actually was elected governor we will
learn more about it I guess on January
29th she tweeted get ready Kerry lake is
holding a rally on Sunday January 29th
you do not want to miss this hashtag
save Arizona if you look at the picture
they use uh it is
it's certainly trumpian uh it's uh
listen if you're if you're only
listening today
um check out Carrie Lakes Twitter and
look at the picture that was selected
um to promote this uh this event in
Arizona
um Carrie Lake lost
Kerry Lake isn't going to be governor uh
I mean if she runs in the future and
wins she could end up as Governor but
none no legal mechanism no maneuvering
no lawsuit none of what Carrie lake has
been raising money for is going to make
her the governor Katie Hobbs is the
governor this is an adject prop rally
and we really have to understand the
history these rallies are very
reminiscent of the fascist rallies that
people like Mussolini and Hitler would
do Mussolini and Hitler would routinely
hold rallies to show their Authority
to get people behind their cause as
misguided as it might have been the
rallies would often include shouting and
chanting and music similar to Modern
Republican rallies the fascist rallies
would include rhetoric that was meant to
make people afraid and make people hate
certain groups of people Trump and Lake
have been doing this regularly you've
got to be afraid of Democrats you've got
to be afraid of marxists you've got to
be afraid of immigrants you've got to be
afraid of academics you've got to be on
media Elites you've got to be afraid of
all of them they're going to come for
your kids you've got to be afraid of
drag queens and trans people and all of
this stuff and Mussolini specifically
would use rallies to vilify opponents as
well that's a trump Carey Lake Classic
our political Rivals must be vilified
Hillary's bad Adam Schiff has a
watermelon head and Joe Biden's a
dangerous Marxist and Hunter Biden and
Barack Obama and all the different
people Obama
um the fascist rallies also have a
tradition of using
language and symbols that are crafted to
manipulate followers
um Hitler was well known for using
dramatic emotive language and grandiose
gestures during his speeches and symbols
there were Nazi symbols all over to
boost morale
Mussolini had this phrase believe obey
fight in his speeches and it's become a
slogan of Italian Fascism and Trump has
this routine he does where you see what
he does we will make America strong
again and we will make America you know
and it kind of just builds and builds
and builds from there there is a big
similarity music was a part of these
fascist and Nazi rallies and Trump has
started to do this thing where he will
lament the downfall of America over a
backdrop of sort of melodramatic music
the similarities are stunning and we're
not saying Trump is Hitler we're not
saying care lake is Mussolini or you
know whoever but it's important to
understand
prior movements that have used this type
of imagery that have used these types of
events we we don't have anyone going to
the Arizona rally
if someone wanted to be our
correspondent and do some interviews it
would be interesting sociologically and
culturally and psychologically to see
who the hell goes to these rallies
anyway
um but you can get it get in touch info
at davidpackman.com if you're like set
up to record interviews and want to want
to go to the event on January 29th we
will be at Trump South Carolina rally
Luke Beasley will be there and then when
I get back from my trip I will have
those clips for you so a lot of wild
wacky and dangerous stuff going on and
maybe there maybe there's one other
thing that I think is worth saying about
this
I didn't use the word cult once in this
particular segment
we can't ignore that storyline either
and on the one hand you have
how reminiscent the Trump Lake type
rallies are of fascist and authoritarian
rallies yes you have that
at the follower level we also have the
cult analysis which is that much of the
when you interview these folks as we
have done many times
the thinking the statements the speech
the rationalization the uh all of it
that we see is very reminiscent of
someone that has been brainwashed into a
cult and to a great degree we've spoken
to experts on Cults and psychologists
and experts on authoritarianism and all
all these different things to a great
degree you have at the top this
authoritarian fascist rally style and
mode of messaging and Below what are
essentially cult members as the
followers and that is a dangerous and
disturbing combination make sure you're
subscribed to the David packman show on
YouTube it's easy it's free I will
update you tomorrow on the aftermath of
the YouTube Fiasco that I told you about
but as of last check let me see here
we have somehow these are unbelievable
numbers added hold on let me see here on
Monday we added 12 000 YouTube
subscribers and yesterday Tuesday we
added about six that's 18
000 new subscribers over the last two
days stunning all from that one clip so
I'll have a full report to you about
that tomorrow but remember you can
subscribe free at youtube.com slash the
David Pacman show
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below